what's left of the function room which
became the epicenter of the Tel Aviv
Riot virtually every stick of furniture
in this venue has been smashed the PA
system has been toppled from the stage
tables have been overturned and the
damage is estimated in excess of half a
million dollars but it's the damage to
community relations which could be the
bigger cost
it will take us six months to recover
from this everything is destroyed what
they didn't destroy they stole they even
took my bicycle
the intensity of the violence between
rival Eritrean groups has sent a
shockwave through Israeli society and
not for the first time the government is
talking about deportation
what happened yesterday across the red
line it's a riot it's Bloodshed these
are riots we cannot accept the business
owners whose livelihoods were shattered
during the riot agree that supporters of
the Asmara government should have their
status reviewed
those who support their government over
there what are they doing here in Israel
they should leave the others who are
refugees there's no problem they will
protect them many Israelis
four hours many Israelis also believe
that those responsible for the kind of
damage and vandalism that was seen on
Saturday should be deported the question
is how and to where and how soon
Paul Brennan Al Jazeera Tel Aviv